[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
politique à table sur lcp la seule
émission qui parle alimentation
agriculture écologie est parfois un peu
politique nous recevons cette semaine
geoffroy roux de bézieux c'est vous qui
allez passer à la casserole et avec moi
pour présenter cette émission jean
pierre montanay bonjour jean pierre
bonjour brigitte bonjour geoffroy roux
de bézieux bonjour bonjour geoffroy roux
de bézieux vous êtes le boss le big boss
le patron des patrons donc là
jean-pierre faut se tenir à carreau sa
question d'avaler de travers sinon c'est
la porte pour faute professionnelle
on est prévenu donc on a mis les petits
plats dans les grands comme vous êtes un
amateur d'épicerie fine puisque vous
avez investi dans la start up en ligne
bien manger point com et c'est pas tout
dans votre groupe note us technologies
vous avez aussi deux marques dans
l'agroalimentaire olivier and co et le
fondant baulois mythique gâteau au
chocolat à des habitants du croisic
alors pour le menu j'avais logiquement
penser à des galettes de blé noir mais
comme vous êtes réservistes et que vous
avez fait votre service militaire au
sein des commandos marine l'unité
d'élite de la marine nationale en clair
jean pierre ce sont les forces spéciales
dont la sélection est l'une des plus
difficiles au monde et bien j'avais
pensé à des sucres lents des pâtes alors
j'ai raison jean pierre bat bien vu des
pâtes mais pas que des patins avec du
poulet aux champignons
mais pas n'importe lesquels des bories
et en dessert tiens tiens un fond de vos
chocolats dans le dos ou des plats
restaurateurs cherche serveurs plus de
200000 emplois sont à pourvoir cet été
salaire à négocier dans les pieds dans
le plat votre caddie de supermarché
passés au crible jusqu'où vont grimper
les prix dans l'alimentation réponse à
suivre allez on passe à table de sa
cuisine et des finances
alors je vous le dis franchement
geoffroy roux de bézieux jamais invités
n'avaient mis autant de temps avant de
nous livrer son choix de repas plus de
deux semaines mais ne vous excuser
surtout pas je comprends votre embarras
et cette lente maturation et oui pas
facile d'assumer librement ses choix
culinaires lorsqu'on est le patron des
patrons et qu'on est né avec une
particule en cette période où notre
assiette et furieusement politisée au
prix de raccourcis disons le
caricaturaux et oui côte de boeuf ou
quinoa le message à la sortie n'est pas
le même alors je vous ai imaginé
transpirant devant votre page blanche
avec ce dilemme en bouche en même temps
assumer vos propres goûts ne pas trahir
votre palais sans faire d'impair ou de
provoc en réclamant par exemple de la
langouste ou des rites von on vous avait
bien retenu la leçon puisque nous voilà
avec du commun du banal du poulet la
deuxième viande la plus consommée en
france elle qui cochent toutes les cases
blanches donc plutôt saine et surtout
bon marché mais pour quand même garder
un certain standing vous avait retoqué
le poulet au vinaigre et finalement vous
avez opté pour ces champignons rare donc
cher voici donc brigitte à poulet aux
morilles c'est peut-être aussi ça votre
conception d'une assiette classique et
gourmande je me trompe geoffroy roux de
bézieux non c'est bien vu le poulet sans
les morilles c'est quand même pas tout à
fait affreuse alors pourquoi les poulets
je veux dire sur un plat de votre enfant
c'est un plat en fait c'est les morilles
vous méritez j'adore les champignons
j'adore les mourir c'est la paix
revienne définitivement la paix est pour
ça que j'ai choisi des mauries et après
le plat le plus naturel pour manger des
maurice et le poulet donc le poulet est
venu si je veux dire après dé mourir
allez à la cueillette aux champignons
c'est ça fait très longtemps je n'ai pas
fait malheureusement je faisais petit et
que mon père donc c'est aussi des
souvenirs d'enfance cents à l'époque et
un peu moins de précaution autour de ce
qu'on ramassait sq ont amassé pain je
n'ai pas fait depuis longtemps mais en
tout cas c'est puis c'est directement
j'ose pas dire de la fourche à la
fourchette parce qu'il ya pas de fourche
mais enfin c'est effectivement un
général ramasser
il y aurait vendu directement vous
imaginiez peut-être alors vous tels que
je vous comprends pas ce que c'est la
mauritanie dès votre choix plein de
moréac un petit boulot
ya quand même quelques nourrit un peu de
jean pierre l'a dit le champignon la
maurice est un champignon de saison vous
êtes attachez vous à la saisonnalité des
produits vous êtes particulièrement
attentifs à cela oui alors sans tomber
dans le politiquement correct à tout
prix je pense qu'on est allé un peu loin
effectivement
à la fois dans la standardisation de
l'alimentation d'une part et dans la
désorganisation de la limitation aucun
moment je veux dire acheter des kiwis de
nouvelle-zélande
au supermarché du coin c'est peut-être
pas la meilleure chose qu'on fait à tous
égards à la fois sur le côté carbone etc
mais même d'un point de vue garder les
gens qui cultivent des avec lui on peut
en faire maintenant en france le tout à
fait et un truc qui m'avait beaucoup
frappé service en régie siens alors je
me suis appuyé un an et demi enfin après
le comte premier confinement donc cette
2020 vise les allées payant la viande et
je tombe sur des steaks de serre
dangereux suède n'ont pas du tout de
nouvelle zélande j'ai rien contre les
all blacks un show pas de me mettre à la
nouvelle et bien maintenant on se dit on
marche un peu sur la tête ce kit est
absolument passionnant mode en demandant
à l'importateur qui était là ou en tout
cas sont présentes en pourquoi il
faisait débat en fait on ne peut vendre
que du steak de maisons parce que c'est
des steaks d'élevage phase et dessert
d'élevage dont qui sont abattues avec
des conditions d'hygiène ils sont
sous plastique avec des bonnes
conditions alors que le cerf européen il
est chassé et et donc on ne sait pas
garantir et c'est vrai qu'il ya un
équilibre à trouver entre le surplus de
normes qu'on met pour des raisons qu'on
peut comprendre et qui pourtant réclamée
par les consommateurs et puis
l'authenticité des produits pense qu'on
a atteint un peu le fond de la piscine
or plus rôle encore je pense en tout cas
moi ce que je vois alors vous pouvez
parler gentiment on a des business que
j'ai acheté dans l'épicerie fine ya
quand même une forte demande
de proximité dans l'autre sens cité
voilà alors avec évidemment toujours un
dilemme pouvoir d'achat parce que ce qui
est bio ce qui plus est en général plus
cher toutes choses égales par ailleurs
voulait pas goûté on vous essayez jeu
god je veux ton iphone facile qui
rappelle celle que vous avez cueilli
avec votre papa et moi je vais en
profiter pour vous dire deux trois
petites choses oui alors même trois
choses je suis remémoré
vous êtes
gourmande alors les morilles fraîches
nero memory seront se ramasse non par en
automne comme la plupart des champignons
je le disais mais à partir d'avril
jusqu'à fin mai donc c'est très court
voilà pourquoi ils sont si rares et si
chez hertz et maury les morilles aime
les endroits ensoleillés au bord des
forêts près des vergers des jardins chez
nous en france on les trouve surtout à
l'est et au sud est mais aussi dans le
périgord en corrèze à l'étranger la mort
y existe à les ramasser en turquie dans
certains pays de l'est est aussi en
chine à la maurit de xincai pas
forcément très bonne la morille second à
la ferme et je vais faire comme il ya la
mort et dulcinée la muraille de lola à
ouidah
j'aurais pu la fête la mairie se
consomme toujours cuite car cru bréhin
dangereuse à elle est toxique cela est
dû à la présence des mots lysine qui
détruisent les globules rouges ceux ci
disparaissent après cinq minutes de
cuisson ou six mois de séchage c'est
pour ça qu'on a souvent souri sécher
attention même cuite si vous abusez sur
les quantités c'est pour ça que c'est
françoise a été très respectueux
on peut risquer une intoxication
alimentaire on recommande généralement
un maximum de six grosses morilles enfin
comment la cuisine ton avec un peu de
beurre août crème en accompagnement de
pâtes comme l'a fait françois ou de la
viande blanche tout comme la truffe sa
saveur est si prononcé qu'une petite
quantité suffit ces champignons
s'accorde parfaitement au jeu aux
asperges au parmesan au vin blanc aux
échalotes et la porta raffinement
supplémentaire au risotto voilà c'est
très bon c'est délicieux oui ça vous
plaît vous à vous aimer non ils sont
très bonnes le poulet ferme ce qui est
pas toujours le cas donc juste un petit
verre de bourgogne pourront alors oui
effectivement car nous sommes désolés le
poulet est ce qu'il faut y voir un
message politique on sait que 45% du
poulet est importé d'ukraine en grande
partie du brésil en est là c'est un peu
un peu trop sophistiqué pour moi non
c'est parce que comme je l'aï dit tout à
l'heure le poulet aux morilles et leur
valeur une fois qu'on a choisi les maury
le poulet bien viennent naturellement
après comme enfin l'ensemble de
l'alimentation je pense qu'on va quand
même régionalisée et c'est pas juste
l'ukraine ça va de sa cible le crâne est
un accélérateur mais on sent d'ailleurs
globalement dans l'industrie soit une
volonté de régionaliser c'est pas la
démondialisation c'est une rééquilibrage
de deux certains cas mais en fait c'est
assez simple à prendre on a poussé
collectivement le principe de
l'économiste ricardo qui va chercher le
meilleur prix partout dans le monde un
peu à l'extrême ça a deux conséquences
des conséquences écologiques de coûts de
transport ils sont un peu exacerbé jour
on perd à vraiment le carbone est ronde
vient de voter une taxe carbone dont
s'est pas encore mis en beauté enfin on
a esquissé le principe d'une taxe
carbone aux frontières mais à 20 c c c
et puis c'est très compliqué à mettre en
place parce que bon donc il ya cet
aspect là et puis l aspect
non pour le mot souveraineté on va dire
autonomie c'est à dire que si
effectivement il n'y a plus qu'un seul
pays qu'une seule usine qui fabrique un
type de produit à la dépendance voilà
alors pour le poulet ce pas le sujet de
l'autonomie mais ça peut être le sujet
de la qualité il ya une demande de
qualité comme je le disais thaler donc
oui ce problème j'ai pas eu la tvb en
plein air soit si on peut penser qu'il a
été dévié la balle à la main il
ressemble et bourg tous les cas ce type
de risque et voilà à dire que s'appeler
bref si c'est pas un poulet brest enfin
ça ressemble un poulet bref ça vous
choque quand même par exemple on parle
souvent de ces cinq 5 légumes qui
faisait la ratatouille française enfin
la ratatouille niçoise et comme
maintenant on importe car on n'a pas
assez d'aubergines passé de courge est
passé de tomates passé doignon est ce
que c'est un peu dommage quand même
qu'on n'ait pas conservé cette
souveraineté alors qu'il ya encore
quelques années on les avait ses légumes
apportés mais la réalité c'est vrai pour
l'industrie fin pour l'agriculture c'est
que il ya une schizophrénie permanente
dont on est tous ceux collectivement
victimes en quelque sorte sa d'un côté
on accumule des normes et des
contraintes qui protège les
consommateurs année ça y est et on le
comprend mais j'allais dire les mêmes en
quelque sorte
veulent consommer local haut rhin maman
si à ramasser des légumes
doivent être faits avec des contraintes
salariales de protection qu'on comprend
mais aussi des contraintes d'hygiène
très drastiques eh ben ça part dans des
pays qui n'ont pas ces contraintes la
haie est une manière plus là je voyais
la taxe carbone aux frontières au fond
ce vers quoi on se dirige l'équipe à
évidence et trouver un équilibre entre
un espèce de protectionnisme et 3 qui on
reviendra pas si vous voulez à belgrade
ont fait tous calibres et ç'a eu
à gérer ce serait peut-être un peu plus
nuancé mais on reviendra pas la théorie
du potager qui consistait tout produire
tard si tu discutes est il ya quelques
mois avec le maire de grande ville
écologistes enfin pas la ville mais le
maire et qui disait oui je vais
transformer les jardins publics en
potager comme ça veut aller vers d'un
ouvrier et on pourra dire on pourra
nourrir la moitié de la population
j'émets un doute voilà un bonus comme
les fermes elles vont ouvrir les
bienveillants la fin d'août quand même
bon donc il ya ce voyez cette extrême
l'a en quelque sorte un extrême et
sociaux qui n'est pas crédible mais le
scénario de son fait tout là où ça coûte
le moins marche pas parce que les
standards ne sont pas les mêmes et du
coup si on a des standards différents il
faut qu'il y ait une forme de protection
intelligente de moi j'appelle pas ça du
protection l'égalisation de la
concurrence c'est à dire que si le
ciment je parlais de complètement autre
chose de ciment turc produit beaucoup
plus de carbone que le ciment européen
faut pas qu'ils puissent entrer dans le
marché européen parce qu'il sera
forcément moins cher produire plus vers
produire plus bio alimentaire que ça
coûte dans 99% des cas plus cher alors
propos d' équilibre la viande avouent
manger du poulet c'est une viande
blanche je les dis c'est pas la plus
mauvaise des dents est ce que vous êtes
flexitariens ce que vous avez et changez
vos habitudes alimentaires en estonie
tofu mais pas politiquement correct
effectivement
un viandard absolue parvient dans
l'absolu mais je mange toujours autant
de viande je bois toujours autant de
vins rouges un peu de vin blanc autre
côté roussel un peu ça mais je n'étais
pas perdue est de ce côté là et
c'est un bon triptyque pourvoi non mais
ce que je sais
il faut pas que le l'acte de manger
deviennent espèce de comment venir enfin
dénonciation politique mais à un moment
il faut il faut aussi trouver un
équilibre là dedans alors on va voir si
vous êtes incollables et c'est le quiz
vous avez accompli votre service
national dans les commandos de marine
brigitte le rappeler avec un feat
cependant l'homme c'était vrai savez
vous à quoi carbure en termes
d'alimentation ces troupes d'élite pour
améliorer leur performance à hobart
céréales banane gingembre et hommos
énergie bol des boulettes aux amandes
coc tonnes des compléments alimentaires
utilisés par des cyclistes
professionnels aidés à l'huile de foie
de morue à quoi carbure t-il alors
historiquement c'est sûrement l'huile de
foie de morue vrai mais la cage
maintenant c'est plutôt les bars
laquelle je sais pas mais alors non
scellées c'est un boss énergie ball
dénoncé alors j'ai appris ça ça veut
dire pour moss pour military optimise id
super food alors il ya un goût
mais alors c'était cité est approuvé
dans des conditions extrêmes par les
forces armées elles procurent un coup de
boost instantanée grâce à l'effet du
guarana super aliments consacré en
caféine et voilà maintenant si vous
étiez commandos de marine aujourd'hui eh
bien vous mangeriez tous les jours des
most énergie parce que ces gosses que
j'utilise ça pour mes triathlon ah bah
voilà mais effectivement c'est moi je
suis de l'époque ben ouais tu dors à
sion avec allah concert mes trucs et de
machins pokéristique
alors 2e quiz en 2016 vous avez repris
olivier n'co donc c'est une pme qui est
spécialisée dans l'huile d'olive haut de
gamme alors est ce que vous êtes
incollables sur cet or liquide lesquels
je serai patient sur l'huile d'olive
sont vrais a il existe trois grands
types fruité vert fruité mûr et fruité
noir vrai ou faux oui ça c'est vrai
alors ça c'est vrai en france il existe
huit huile aop
à aop après je les compte dans ma tête
je lisais des vies des rayons de oliver
gré et non mais il ya les l'union 6ème
déchets cl c'est l'ordre de grandeur est
ce que ces mythes tout ce que ces neuf
fois ce que c'est cette un doute
m'habite comme
vous avez raison d'avoir ces sept
on comptabilise une bonne réponse il
n'existe qu'une seule aoc vrai ou faux
il n'existe qu'une seule aoc oui je
crois que c'est grave eh ben ça c'est
vrai l'huile de provence et puis en
france l'olivier se cultive depuis 1500
ans vrai ou faux même plus que ça non
beaucoup plus que ça mais bien sûr c'est
un arbre qui est plus que millénaire on
a retrouvé des amphores d'huile d'olive
dans les dents béhi non ça s'appelle non
des péniches qui est pas des pénis mais
bon des bateaux phéniciens qui avait
fait naufrage ça se conserve d'ailleurs
c'est la seule chose qui est plus les
gens savent pas me permet de donner un
peu de sens et que l'huile d'olive perd
son goût
contrairement au vin en vieillissant ah
oui donc il faut prendre une huile
d'olive quelques années c'est ça alors
de l'année quand elles sont millésimé
mais c'est pas souvent le cas millésime
les huiles et en tout cas essayer de les
récolter ça dépend des pays bas 20
millions entre octobre et novembre est
la meilleure huile c'est l'huile con
qu'on déguste dans les quatre à six mois
qui suivent parce qu'elle est à l'aller
on a passé tu habitais amène un peu plus
amer plus mais elle est beaucoup plus
parfumé venir y vont sont vieillissants
je trouve aussi elle vit avec ses deux
ce qu'on appelle le feu tu es noir et
l'historiquement en provence on prenait
finances il fallait la conserver mais en
fait les moins bonnes et d'un point de
vue vous savez c'est très bon pour la
santé plein d'oligo-éléments évidemment
plus les récentes plus les aliments sont
efficaces et alors olivier le sait dans
quel pays c'est olivier les présents
alors en revanche on est présent dans 17
pays et en origine on fait tout le tour
mais dernière assez peu en france parce
qu'on cultive peu en france à la france
ait un ou deux pour cent la production
d'eau des gros producteurs c'est espagne
italie portugal grèce portugal grèce et
on a maintenant un alors le magret mais
c'est parfois aux références cette année
une huile marocaine
parce que il ya aussi
comme dans l'un des qualités qui qui qui
doivent progresser nous on allait y
colog voiliers qui goûte qui note que
toutes les chaque année on sélectionne
une quarantaine de propriétés qui sont
pas toujours les mêmes mais dans un pool
de 200 propriétés cette année on a
sélectionné une huile marocaine des
mélanges d'huiles c'est ça c'est pas
comme le vent alors non non non nous on
est on est mono propriétaire ça peut
être plus ri variétale puisqu'il ya
aussi des variétés d'olives est on est
on est millésimé alors coefficient les
huiles que vous achetez en grande
distribution sont mélangés comment voyez
l'avenir de mes deux livres parce qu'on
plante un j'ai vu en espagne un plan
beaucoup d'olivier mais en italie dans
les pouilles notamment qui était
vraiment le berceau d'huile d'olive avec
cette maladie vous allez me parler de la
maladie s'il ya des millions d'arbres
qui ont été abattus toit du millier est
ce que ces minoritaires on se monte à la
télé oui on le dire la vérité ah oui ne
vous inquiétez pas non mais je
m'inquiète pas mais avec toujours des
lycées remboursé par la l'union
européenne donc oui mais je pensais aux
habitants des bouches pour ces risques
d'épidémies il y en a eu quelques unes
en corse ou si globalement l'olivier se
porte bien le mil de livres se porte
bien ce qu'il faudrait c'est
des règles plus strictes pour éviter les
mélanges
il ya malheureusement dans quelques pays
que je ne citerai pas de tentation de
mélanger les huiles les huiles pas
seulement au sein des huiles d'olive
je vois plus d'olive et à des aliments
là on a déjà parlé relaté du bien sûr et
c'est malheureusement des fraudes alors
par contre sur l'avenir moi je suis très
optimiste parce que c'est un c'est
vraiment dans le ce que demandent les
gens c'est à dire c'est un aliment très
sain c'est un beau c'est ce qu'on
appelle un alicament c'est à dire que
j'ai pas si vous feriez pas bondir
quelques nutritionniste et quand même
parce qu'en terme de calories une huile
d'olive une
identité en fait non mais il ya tous les
oligo éléments qui en 2000 qui sont
extrêmement bon ce que je lui dis pas
qu'il faut pas comparer moi je suis pas
certain si tous les matins je suis passé
au régime espagnol créer deux au lieu de
mettre de l'aqdr d'accord du beurre et
de la confiture oui je m'étalais comme
tomato vous mettez de l'huile d'olive
sur un pain grillé ses délicieux et
c'est meilleur pour la santé alors sans
d'automne alors en france le repas vous
le savez occupent une large place essais
souvent autour d'un bon plat que se
racontent les meilleures histoires c'est
la brève de comptoir
alors je vois votre vision vous a
demandé de réfléchir à une histoire
autour d'un repas est ce qu'on en a une
qui vous est revenu particulièrement à
l'esprit je pourrais vous parler des
banquiers de rugbyman qu'angers
terribles images mais je suis pas sûr
que ce soit exactement le lieu idéal non
apple drôle
ouais mais bon on est preneur non et
j'ai quelques souvenirs le premier c'est
marc blondel quitté l'ancien dirigeant
de force ouvrière donc il ya des années
moi je jeu des jeunes patrons je me
retrouve un déjeuner croissance plus en
face de lui très sympa en parle de
corrida de trucs de masham lui l'était
l'ancienne était pavée gagnent pas
vraiment un genre à l'époque c'était pas
voilà c'était pas l'ambiance et à la fin
il m'a dit bof on vous vous êtes là pour
faire du pognon moi je suis là pour vous
le piquet
[Rires]
lui mais c'est bien et puis le train des
dates elle est à venir puisque j'ai fait
un débat
sur france télévisions là il ya à peu
près un mois ou deux avec jean luc
mélenchon
débat qui a été plutôt
apprécié des spectateurs puisque au lieu
de se mettre sur la gueule comme
objectivement tout le monde et pendant
vos confrères journalistes l'espérait on
s'est écouté à constater nos désaccords
mais on l'a fait avec courtoisie et un
peu du mois et à la fin d'un qui m'a
proposé d'inviter à déjeuner je lui dis
maintenant vous m'avez fait les poches
mais je vous paierai quand même
l'addition donc on a le déjeuner n'est
pas fixée j'attendais qu'il soit battu
donc voilà maintenant qui veut être
premier ministre ça va prendre un peu
voilà alors dans la restauration les
patrons ont du mal à recruter
conséquences de la crise sanitaire c'est
le dessous des plats
[Musique]
et oui tous les métiers de la
restauration ne font plus recette depuis
le coc vide il est très difficile de
recruter un serveur ou un cuisinier en
dépit de la hausse de 16,3 pour cent des
salaires dans l'hôtellerie restauration
les patrons ne trouve pas de main
d'oeuvre reportage dans le cotentin de
stéphanie des pierres
c'est l'un des plus gros restaurant de
cherbourg avec vue sur le port
gaël le patron cherche des salariés
désespérément il lui manque deux ou
trois personnes en salle et en cuisine
en france 150 mille personnes ont quitté
la restauration après la pandémie alors
pour appâter les candidats la profession
a décidé d'augmenter les salaires sans
sera pas suffisant françois mais on l'a
déjà fait celui et on
a des problèmes ne sait pas que le
problème parce que le plus paisible dans
la profession c'est qu'on a bien
travaillé le matin au marché soit 3h 4h
et on revient le soir jusqu'à minuit ça
c'est bien des problèmes le plus
important que faire des coupures cette
coupure est devenu un repoussoir alors
qu'elle a entamé une petite révolution
en cuisine sur certains postes il y à
une personne à midi une autre le soir
mais ça ne suffit toujours pas julie son
assistante de direction poste des offres
d'emploi un peu partout elle ne reçoit
des cv qu'au compte gouttes et les
candidats deviennent exigeants donc
large et demi que je recherchais un
serveur 39 heures par semaine j'ai bien
dit qu'on a mis 2 jours de repos
consécutifs
qui avait une mutuelle c'est un cdd de 9
mois et on ne met pas de salaire parce
qu'on sait très bien que de toute façon
ça va être négocié donc
donc voilà les gens aujourd'hui c'est un
peu le mercato en fait ils font les
entreprises les unes après les autres et
c'est au plus offrant on fait
alors on a reçu quelques uns ce matin
avec le chef vraiment un profil super
sympa quelqu'un de plus 30 ans
originaire de l'île de la réunion chef à
l'île de la réunion
mais la veux faire un essai un essai
d'un jour et demi quoi pour être sûrs
quoi c'est pas vous qui demandait à fait
intérêt des 16,50 alors c'est les
candidats qui demandent à faire une
percée et qui nous impose en fait un
jour ou un jour et demi dans cette aile
je vous recommande donc on jongle comme
ça tout le temps tout le temps tout le
temps tout le temps avec cette pénurie
de main d'oeuvre le rapport de force
s'est inversé dans la restauration ce
sont désormais les demandeurs d'emploi
qui négocie
alors geoffroy roux de bézieux on voit
bien qu'il ya un problème de fond
structurel c'est à dire qu'il ya de
repas à midi et le soir et que ça fait
des horaires à rallonge et que et bien
les gens ne veulent plus travailler
comme ça est-ce que vous avez une
solution comme en fait on pas midi et
soir non ça je vois pas on va pas
changer facilement dans le lot protège
d'une phrase c'est juste le rapport de
force s'est inversé mais je veux dire il
s'est inversée dans beaucoup de métiers
on parlait autrefois des métiers en
tension en fait la question maintenant
c'est quel métier n'est pas en tension
moi les seuls patrons que je rends
compte qu'ils n'ont pas de difficulté
recommencer ce qui recrutent pas
et la restauration s'est exacerbée parce
que les salaires étaient bas
et que les horaires étaient vraiment
très contraint il très étiré 2-1 3-2
mi-temps avec en train de travailler
enfin il est temps la branche est côté
patronat et côté syndicats a essayé de
trouver des aménagements mais
malheureusement c'est comme le c'est
comme le travail du week-end dans le
commerce si les clients venaient en
semaine aux horaires au moins c'est tout
irait bien sauf que les clients se font
des salariés voyez il n'y a pas de
solution absolument magique les salaires
ont augmenté
ils vont continuer à augmenter
visiblement ça ne suffit pas et c'est ça
suffit pas ça a été en fait très marqué
je pense parle sur la restauration parce
que au fond le coc vide plus le
télétravail
agit un peu comme une prise de
conscience de dire il ya d'autres
métiers et ces gens ils n'ont pas
disparu il faut qu'ils vivent donc ils
peuvent vivre des allocations pendant un
moment il faut quand même qu'ils donc
ils ont été faire autre chose on a vu
exploser les micro entrepreneurs et on a
vu que c'était pas un métier essentiel
puisque on va fermer les restaurants je
pense qu'aussi ça brille ça a pu jouer
donc il ya tout de moi j'étais là ce
week-end guinée dans mon restaurant
favori au croisic
patron à 82 ans il était en salle avec
son épouse est ce qu'ils ne trouvent pas
que il était obligé de 2,2
donc et ils m'ont il a commencé comme à
14 ans comme garçons de salle donc il
connaît le métier donc donc mais enfin
oui c'est quand même dur donc en temps
là le rapport de force s'est inversé
c'est à dire qu'en fait ce sont
aujourd'hui les serveurs les cuisiniers
qui imposent leurs prix du gasoil à moi
je viens pas à temps par mois temps mais
aussi le l'ambiance le mais j'ai eut
raconté le cancer exécutif du medef on a
une femme qui dirige une emprise de
transports qu'à une cinquantaine de
camions elle me disait moi quand j'ai un
client pendant un candidat qui se
présente je laisse tout tomber je vais
le recevoir c'est quasiment pour savoir
comment le convaincre de venir donc les
chauffeurs routiers c'est pareil il ya
alors il ya des étés s'ils voulaient
spécifiques sur certains métiers mais ce
qu'il faut comprendre aussi c'est que
démographiquement on arrive à un moment
où il ya de moins en moins de deux
jeunes qui arrivent sur le marché du
travail est de plus en plus de vue
puisqu'il ya un phénomène démographique
ont donc l'accroissement
de la quantité de gens disponibles pour
travailler va se réduire c'est un
phénomène qui s'il ya une chose dont on
est sûr en économie c'est la démographie
leur est bon c'est que c'est la
confiance
enfin on est toujours surpris voilà j'ai
croisé un grand restaurateur lundi
effectivement il m'a dit ce que vous
êtes en train mais diable et surtout il
a fini par me dire c'est insoluble est
ce que vous êtes d'accord avec lui non
c'est en jouant sur les salaires ça ne
joue plus y en jouant sur même
l'aménagement du temps de travail qui
est la troisième voie quels sont les
autres levier sur lequel on a je crois
pas que ça soit insoluble
rien n'est jamais un solide en économie
on fait l'économie de marché c'est
finalement il n'y a pas plus adaptable
pas pu darwini alo'o trouve toujours le
moyen de rester mais comme toute hâte de
transition je pense qu'on est vraiment
dans une période de transition sur cinq
centres de métier qui vont voir leur
salaires augmenter leurs conditions de
travail revue à maman au final c'est le
consommateur qui va en payer le prix
restauration en gros c'est 70% de coûts
de main d'oeuvre donc les salaires
augmentent et vont se trouver donc on va
avoir des équilibres qui vont se
remettre en place mais comme toujours
que c'est au moment où ça bouge que
c'est compliqué est ce qu'on pourrait
imaginer par exemple on a vu que de
grands restaurateurs des chefs étoilés
arrêter de servir à l'heure du déjeuner
est ce qu'on pourrait imaginer que
soient plus à emporter peut-être à
l'heure du déjeuner les enfants déjà
beaucoup exemple ils ont pris beaucoup
de 2,2 à tous les systèmes de livraison
mois et quelques excès dont on peut
parler mais fonctionne donc c'est c'est
finalement finalement un phénomène assez
classique dans l'économie c'est un
changement de paramètres qui amène un
changement de business model simplement
on va là rien de temps à se réaliser ça
veut dire que dans si je savais je serai
certainement plus riches parce que
j'aurais acheté les bonnes entreprises
au bon moment donc non mais je vais
cesser
il faut pas croire que je sais que je
vais porter les économistes mais
l'économie c'est pas une chance dur
c'est une sciences comportementales pour
beaucoup donc c'est difficile d'imaginer
l'ensemble des acteurs économiques du
secteur la restauration c'est quoi ces
les clients les restaurateurs et les
salariés c'est ce trio va s'adapter à
ces nouvelles conditions capter des
restaurateurs vont changer de métier
des gens qui vont effectivement moins
faire que le soir colas des jeux
auxquels déjà parce que aussi le cas de
figure où vous êtes dans un quartier de
bureaux et les clients vont se consommer
différemment est-ce que ça va prendre
dix ans prend manquent pas mais est-ce
que ça va se résoudre en douze mois
probalement pas non plus les
restaurateurs ne disent qu'une des
solutions c'est aussi d'embaucher des
étudiants ou des travailleurs étrangers
et qui n'ont pas forcément de papier ce
que vous pensez qu'il va falloir
assouplir certaines règles pour
permettre à ces populations du pouvoir
travailler légalement en france pour
justement régler une part il ya deux
questions dans votre question c'est est
ce que dans les 10 20 années la france
l'europe a besoin de main d'oeuvre
étrangère pour remplir
les capacités pollution s'en chargent
pas que dans la restauration très
probablement oui du point de vue
économique démographique
mathématiquement c'est vrai presse pose
une question très simple c'est
l'intégration de ses populations dans
des modes de vie sont pas forcément ceux
qui connaissent dans leur pays ils sont
rentrés sur le terrain polémique que
vous connaissez
nous on a un rôle à jouer parce qu'il
n'y a pas meilleur facteur d'intégration
que travailler et à une semaine j'étais
à clermont ferrand d'une petite
entreprise de chaudronnerie il y avait
un réfugiés érythréens
qui a dû être clandestin en réalité
parce que d'après mes copains passent il
était réfugié politique n'est pas son
statut qui a réussi à trouver un
parcours de formation
donc il est dans l'alternance école
feront école de français et qui fait de
la mécanique et dans une entreprise et
on voit bien que là il est en train de
deux appartements ou payer des impôts
aux fins d impôt de cotisations sociales
vous vous intégrez voilà après sur les
clandestins moi je peux pas encourager
les restaurateurs ont peur d'être un
destin évidemment c'est d'abord inégal
et où ma question est ce qu'il faut pas
à soupe normes il ya un truc qui
s'appelle la séculaire valls
qui est le bon équilibre ca je crois
qu'au bout alors j'ai pu le exactement
le détail mais au bout d'une certaine
période
employés
donc intrigue mais sur le papier on peut
être connu et je crois pas qu'il faille
non plus si vous voulez ouvrir
entre guillemets lever un appel d'air
oui alors je n'aime pas le mot appel
d'air ce qui donne un peu ce qui est des
gens qui souffrent vraiment et qui est
qu'ils quittent leur pays mais
il faut trouver le juste milieu ça fait
un peu langue de bois à dire ça entre ce
que l'entreprise par les entreprises
françaises et européennes je pense pour
le sujet il ya les allemands on
connaisse le ch est beaucoup mieux que
nous puisque ils sont à quatre
championnats une démographie qui est
beaucoup plus décliné en deux colonnes
dont ils ont fait preuve depuis depuis
très longtemps et trouver cette
intégration s'assurer c'est toute la
difficulté que les gens s'attaquent bien
dans la société il n'y a pas mieux que
le travail trail c'est quand même la
manière de devenir citoyen comme en
quelque sorte pendant quelques mois vous
nous disiez les jeunes finalement ne
veulent plus travailler autant ils ont
changé larges épaules du seul nom et
branchez vous qu'il était d'accord il
n'y a pas un changement de mentalité je
me méfie toujours de leurs réflexions
dans du vieux cons qui dit les jeunes
veulent plus travailler les jeunes peu
plus aussi déjà cela j'ai travaillé mais
pas peut-être autant il ya des questions
alors
il ya plusieurs choses à mon avis pour
autant que je puisse le voir en grand le
poste de stations qui met rien la
première chose qu'ils aient mais plutôt
chez les diplômés la quête de sens le
sujet bon pourquoi je fais ça et une
hiérarchie plus facilement remis en
question ça ça remet en question
beaucoup les managers c'est à dire que
historiquement le savoir permettait
l'autorité et comme le savoir est
totalement partagée par les réseaux
j'ai un souvenir moi c'est assez
frappant quand j'étais j'avais monté
virgin mobile qui était face à free
quand free s'est lancé gvt et on était
400 ou 500 et 500 directeur de la
stratégie kevin idée de ce qu'il fallait
faire quoi et une emprise s'est pas
complètement un soviet il faut aussi
quelqu'un décide à la fin des fins donc
il ya ce phénomène là il ya un deuxième
phénomène avis qui est ces jeunes qui
sont pas idiots savent qu'ils vont
travailler beaucoup plus longtemps que
nous et qui vont changer de métier
d'entreprise et donc ils ont une vision
plus
pas comment dire utilitariste plus
transactionnel de deux rapports au
travail je rapporte rails et à
l'entreprise
parce qu'ils savent aussi qu'une
entreprise est pas éternel qu'un métier
et paternelle que des hauts et des bas
bien sûr jamais bien sûr bien sûr le
rapport c'est évident et ça s'est
accentué avec locaux vides parce que le
télétravail qui a plein davantage peut
aussi
désocialisés on a eu ce phénomène qu'on
connaît tous tas de jeunes entrant dans
des entreprises qui connaissaient pas
leur collègue ou d'un ennemi parce que
ils connaissaient que l'écran zoom quoi
masqué en plus oui en plus lorsque alors
bien se nourrir coûte coûte cher et de
plus en plus cher car les prix flambent
l'inflation fait exploser le panier de
la ménagère on en parle et on met les
pieds dans le plat
louis brigitte hannon et rayons de
supermarchés c'est la valse des
étiquettes et ans et encore le pire est
à venir à hausse des prix en mars qui
devrait grimper en avril et s'accélérer
jusqu'à cet été pas d'accalmie me dit-on
avant 2023
quelles sont dans les rayons les
aliments les plus durement touchés c'est
une enquête de miles morin et d'antoine
coûteux
le paquet de pâtes peut-il devenir un
produit de luxe on pourrait le croire
tant le prix des produits alimentaires
ont augmenté depuis plusieurs mois bilan
des courses à la sortie d'un supermarché
les produits du quotidien deviennent de
moins en moins accessible quelque chose
de tout to basic cette baguette là il
n'y a pas si longtemps que cela elle est
à 69 centimes maintenant 74 par exemple
y en a acheté les sacs avant 37 euros
maintenant c'est 40 ceinture ou la
france ont fait des passes sur certains
produits comprenez avant maintenant on
nous prends moi comme la viande
les oeufs le poulet viande le week-end
et les semaines j'essaie de
je triche corps et puis bon le plus gros
bras pour les enfants quoi je me prises
pour nourrir ma famille selon les
chiffres de 60 millions de consommateurs
le prix d'un panier moyen a augmenté de
3,3 pour cent par rapport à l'année
dernière plus fortes hausses pour les
pâtes avec 12,3 pour cent les viandes
surgelées 4,2 pour cent les huiles
végétales le café ou les légumes en
conserve plus de 3% les raisons de cette
flambée des prix sont multiples des
récoltes très mauvaise l'année dernière
des gels tardifs la reprise économique
soudaine après locaux vides 19 qui a
fait exploser la demande et la guerre en
ukraine devrait aggraver la situation
l'impact de la guerre en ukraine
n'apparaît pas aujourd'hui dans ces
hausses de prix on peut le voir
éventuellement dans les céréales
évidemment du petit déjeuner les huiles
végétales également ce sont des produits
qui sont pas périssable immédiatement
les distributeurs ont des stocks il
écoule actuellement les stocks à
l'ancien prix mais dès que ces stocks
sont seront vides
les nouveaux prix vont être beaucoup
beaucoup plus important que ce qu'on
connaît encore aujourd'hui une future
augmentation des prix que confirment les
industriels des négociations sont en
cours entre les fabricants et les grands
magasins pour définir les nouveaux prise
à appliquer les représentants du secteur
préviennent ces hausses de prix pourrait
être amenée à durer
l'agriculteur à des surcoûts
l'industriel a aussi des surcoûts et
donc tout ça doit être répercutée dans
une certaine mesure dans les prix qui
sont ensuite affichés aux consommateurs
dans les magasins on n'a aucune
visibilité sur la fin du conflit sur
la disponibilité de toutes les matières
premières agricoles ou tous les autres
intrants
industrielle par exemple vous avez une
crise sur le vert sur le papier sur le
carton sur plastique en fait tout le
monde a besoin de ces matières premières
au même moment selon certains analystes
la hausse des prix atteindra un pic à
l'été à un niveau comparable à la crise
de 2008 elle devrait se poursuivre
jusqu'en 2023
alors geoffroy roux de bézieux question
un peu provoc à cette hausse des prix
qu'on voit tout ça dans nos caddies est
ce que c'est la faute à la guerre est ce
que la guerre a bon dos ou est ce que
c'est la faute de la grande distribution
qui profitent des circonstances alors la
grande distribution elle y est pour rien
elle est plutôt en train d'essayer de
bloquer les augmentations présidentielle
non il ya une ovation des matières
premières moi je fais un fondant au
chocolat d'un kelly à quoi
du beurre et des oeufs et des poules et
les augmentations et le beurre c'est
plus 46 46% 46% les oreilles à la grippe
aviaire qui se greffent dessus en france
on est à 50 quelque chose et même la
barquette d'aluminium dans lequel on met
le gâteau nantais un fondant au chocolat
souvent les 86% le transport pour
transporter votre fondamentaux donc non
il ya des vrais augmentation au final du
gâteau mais c'est toute la galère nous
on n'est pas en grande distribution
qu'on a plus de antrim et de facilité à
passer une partie du prix au
consommateur final mais évidemment
annoncé le consommateur final qui va
dire c'est trop cher alors dedans il ya
du spéculatif il ya une partie d'eux
parce qu'elle espérait parce que le coc
vide un réduit terriblement les
transports et d'après vous avez vu ce
phénomène de
reprise très violente qui fait que le
container vrsac et le un peu le le prix
du conteneur c'est en gros le prix du
transport est passé en gros de 2500
dollars 1 16 mille dollars donc il ya eu
un effet spéculatifs qui à revenir mais
ya des choses plus structurelle
on ne cultive pas assez pour nous et la
population modèles et en europe on avait
commencé à restreindre les surfaces
cultivées et notamment le grinder
donc je pense que là les tic européenne
finalement qu'il faut pas prendre tombé
dans le brussels bashing mais il y avait
une philosophie un peu malthusienne
et je pense que le coville a rebattu les
cartes et on se dit à une forme
l'autonomie stratégique c'est pas que
les semi conducteurs et le titane c'est
aussi bêtement le beurre les oeufs et le
lait quoi est-ce qu'on peut produire
plus en france on en a les moyens oui
j'espère oui alors il ya un grand débat
et c'est là où ça devient un peu plus
compliqué sur l'utilisation ou pas
d'engrais de pesticides ogm et donc il
ya un moment où il faut faire l'
équilibre entre produire plus en
quantité et produire plus en qualité
mais globalement il faut qu'on retrouve
une forme de souveraineté alimentaire
en europe encore une fois je raisonne un
peu après vous avez fait même la guerre
en ukraine où l'ukraine était si on
disait autrefois le grenier à blé de
l'urss aurait dès lors ni à blé de
l'europe il grenier à colza puisque vous
avez plus d'huile de corée du nord
et alors j'allais venir j'entendais le
monsieur qui disait la baguette a est
passé de jeu plus à 74 centièmes 4
centimes bon c'est cinq centimes de plus
si je comprends que ça le chagrine mais
j'étais en tunisie là il ya trois
semaines le pré le les tunisiens sont le
pays qui mangent le plus de pain par
habitant plus que nous figurez vous
prend dans quelque chose qu'on leur a
laissé d'air et la baguette est
subventionné à 15 centimes depuis
toujours
parce que c'est un produit première
nécessité donc il ya un prix
bloquer quoi
ça va poser un problème si c'est durable
très significatif parce que c'est à dire
que ça veut dire que la dialyse obligés
d'emprunter enfin les les pays émergents
va être obligé de d'emprunter 22,2 ce
s'endetter pour acheter les matières
premières qu'elle dont elles peuvent pas
d'égypte a peur aussi et bien sûr parce
que un des défauts de cette extrême
mondialisation c'est ça c'est d'avoir
commis a poussé à ne plus utiliser les
que les cultures locales - nourrissante
moins efficace un teint et de trop
dépendre et finalement c'est un peu ce
que nous on a découvert sur les masques
un moment du cabinet peu découvre
avec le pays est récusée pays où c'est
assez inflammable c'est qu'en tunisie la
révolution de 2008 a démarré
effectivement pour des problèmes de prix
sous les matières concernant les
inflations devrait se poursuivre dans
les mois qui viennent alors je fais
attention je veux dire je suis moi je
suis très prudent parce que je pas si
vous venez en juin 2020 à tout le monde
annonce est le mur des faillites le
million de chômeurs moi j'avais dit
écoutez je me sens pas les choses comme
ça je pense que ça va repartir très vite
m'en fous que j'ai eu raison là au mois
de novembre tout le monde disait un
petit saut d'inflation et puis ça va pas
durer moi je suis de ceux qui pensent
qu'on est
reparti pour
cycle d'inflation qui est difficile à
prévoir c'est la fameuse histoire du du
dentifrice une fois qu'ils les sacs et
les youtube par la rentrée et ça renvoie
au sujet précédent c'est-à-dire comment
gérer intelligemment le ce qu'on appelle
la boucle l'inflation salaire puisque
ces spirales relation évidemment et les
gîtes et les syndicats de salariés les
salariés des rues de latin syndicats
pour demander des augmentations de
salaires pour compenser ce qui est
parfaitement légitime mais évidemment
l'industriel voyant ses coûts augmenter
surtout dans des fruits de manoeuvre va
le refléter dans les prix et on rentre
dans une logique qui est pas du tout
évidente l'inflation s'est jamais une
bonne nouvelle c'est ça l'allemagne à
l'inflation est ce que vous pensez qu'on
attend c'est en espagne 6 % en espagne
on atteindre des scores pareil chez nous
ou les dispenses je vais très prudent
d'abord parce que c'est que fois auto
auto nourrissant ses prophéties voyez ce
que je veux dire circulation donc je ne
sais pas vous dire aujourd'hui on est en
train de découvrir ce que notre
génération d'entrepreneurs ne
connaissais pas c'est à dire comment on
fait pour passer dans la chaîne de
valeur des augmentations en aval et en
amont oui en amont pardon est ce qu'on
est pas c'est ce qu'on dépasse pas
qu'elles sont pérennes et son papa une
c'est la question que se posent tous les
tous les industriels mais c'est à moins
de cette augmentation de salaire elles
vont venir quand même temps elles vont
elles sont venues puisque vingtaine ce
qu'on appelle les aot
négociations annuelles obligatoires qui
ont eu lieu alors sont pas toutes
terminées mais en général c'est au début
de l'année la moyenne qu'on nous a
remonté entre 3 et 3 et demi donc c'est
beaucoup plus que tout ce qu'on a connu
mais effectivement si l'inflation
continue à monter il y aura certainement
des demandes de retrait du mais
complémentaires le smic va augmenter de
2,6 pour cent
au mois de mai puisqu'il ya un système
automatique du coup le smic augmente et
ça fait augmenter beaucoup des chemins
donc oui ces temps là la chose la plus
inquiétante devant nous c est ce qu on
est face à un nouveau paradigme
économique et comment s'adaptent les
entreprises après on a su faire dans le
passé on sera fermée mais c'est un petit
peu la discussion on avait sur les
embauches est ce que les entreprises
aujourd'hui il y avait souvent des
tickets restaurants dans les entreprises
est ce que l on pourrait imaginer que
l'entreprise pèsent davantage sa part
tickets restaurants pour aider sans
forcément augmenter trop les salaires
c'est une manière d'augmenter les
salaires en payant moins de charges et
donc ça peut faire partie des choses que
je crois qu'il faut réfléchir même
globalement on a proposé au gouvernement
qu'il n'a pas repris pour le moment
d'avoir un chèque essence à la à la main
de l'entreprise pour distinguer entre
ceux qui viennent en voiture et même un
tiers de ceux qui viennent en voiture ce
qui vient devant on oublie un peu quand
on vit à paris mais 80% des salles et
prennent leur voiture pour aller
travailler alors ceux qui font cinq
kilomètres peut-être qu'ils pourraient
trouver autre chose et à dubaï enfin
quand fait 30 km matin 30 km soit on ne
peut pas dire en vélo quoi si on peut
mais tu as fait pareil est ce que vous
sentez que les patrons d'agroalimentaire
alors qu'on renégocie les débats je
sonne c'est qu'il le demande très très
longtemps repoussé
des adhérents du medef des deux côtés
donc je fais attention à 6 mai mais il
ya effectivement un bêta sans grande
distribution et les patrons de la grande
traque te ment il ya un bras de fer
parce qu'effectivement la grande
déception dit non je veux pas augmenter
mépris pour pas provoquer de l'inflation
donc prenez sur vos marges entre
guillemets et assez justement les
patrons industriels disent matin des
nous on a nos échanges koshita c'est à
dire les matières premières l'énergie
puisque
dans l'agroalimentaire on consomme de
l'énergie par construction comme un pot
de confiture faut faire une étude avec
de la vapeur faire bref les coûts
augmentent donc il faut que je trouve un
moyen de répercuter ça dans la loi égal
il y avait un mécanisme qui a obligé en
fait à avoir une marge de 10% michel
edouard leclerc dit il faut revenir
peut-être sur cette mesure là où au
moins temporairement pour qu'ils
puissent réduire ses marges ça ça
pourrait permettre de noms mais je ne
sais pas si c'est la bonne solution je
ne sais pas si c'est la bonne solution
ce qui est sûr c'est que c'est très
particulier en france ce bras de fer est
exacerbée en france parce que la dent
discipline très concentré et donc sacré
forcément une tension allez on va passer
à présent au dessert et c'est le péché
mignon
alors péché mignon voici venu le temps
du sucré avec se fondant au chocolat
sans doute une passion pour vous mais
aussi un clin d'oeil qui n'est pas
passée inaperçue car vous le business
man gourmand vous avez donc croquer le
fondant baulois en rachetant cette
société en 2018 qui depuis 1981
confectionne donc un gâteau fondant à
partir d'éléments noble 1 vous l'avez
dit tout alors puisqu'ils sont très
chers alors chez françoise nous a
préparés se fondant donc c'est le match
entre le vôtre et celui de chez
françoise vous l'avais déjà dit et pas
résisté alors je suis mal lu chez
françois c'est pas tout à fait un
fondant au chocolat large discussion
d'en bas un fondant au chocolat fameux
palais oui mais surtout il ya là il ya
deux couches et de la génoise donc c'est
une voix lasse et autres desserts que je
ne critiquerai pas pour être gentil avec
france 24 ont pris sur la marchandise
non mais alors le fond dans blow c'est
un truc très très original parce que
c'est un recettes donc pas si ancienne
que ça au fond 1980 qui était vendu sur
le marché et donc qu'ils étaient
reprises et qui a une spécificité c'est
que ça se conserve hambourg du
réfrigérateur sans conservateur alors ça
se conserve quatre semaines ça se
conserve pas mais il ya plus naturel il
est bon et manger avant donc
il reste vu sa voix sur les sites de
vente cinq allemands comme et 6 4
semaines
alors qu'il y à du beurre d eux qui sont
le plus difficile est donc selon lui
tout est dans la recette et il nous
arrive régulièrement par une très grosse
entreprise ont fait
25 salariés voyez donc c'est artisanal
enfin y compris les comètes les
boutiques et c'est donc dans l'atelier
qui pas vraiment une usine vous avez dit
personnes qui travaillent et c'est une
recette qui nous arrive de rater bah oui
c'est à dire que comme en cuisine ben on
a des revenus à leur bus et parfois des
troubles normalement une grosse et
oui enfin je connais en fait la recette
c'est pas la recette au sens ingrédients
c'est le procédé bayer plus que la
recette comme dans une recette
d'ailleurs c'est
industrialisés
c'est très artisanal à tel point qu'on
travaille que laboratoire de chimie
alimentaire pour essayer de justement
d'essayer de comprendre comment se forme
le gâteau essayer de leur prêt parce que
on est en fait on vend tout ce qu'on
produit on vend des demandes en france
ou hermé demande à l'export justement là
on vient d'expédier un conteneur à dubai
on est des gens qui nous fait du mal
c'est pas trés carbone free joue la
corde mais un bon et
on essaie de comprendre pourquoi et
comment on arrive à avoir cette
conservation en noir du frigo sans
conservateur alors on avance et comme
nous sommes encore en pleine campagne
présidentielle et bien nous nous
intéressons aux us et coutumes de
l'elysée et aux habitudes des
présidences et le quiz présidentielle
alors à l'elysée les épouses des chefs
de l'état brigitte avaient leur mot à
dire sur la cuisine et ont leur mot à
dire alors quelle première dame de la
vème république se cache derrière les
affirmations c'est le macho comme
questionnaire c'est un peu macho face à
ces gens disent un peu me to hell a
ramené donc cette fameuse première dame
en cachette des boîtes de petits pois
que son mari adorait b oui j -p elle
veillait à ce que le sommelier ne
servent pas de vin blanc à son époux
s'est elle imposée parfois ses recettes
qu'elle déniche est dans la revue des
travaux et des elle faisait la chasse
aux gaspillages en cuisine qui suis-je
vème république première dame ça
rigolait alors il ya yvonne talent est
remonté parce que j'ai pu commettre
l'écran sont
des boîtes de petits pois elle veille à
ce que le sommet soit autant qu'ivan
j'hésite entre les petits pois le a et
le sait alors non sinon c'est tout c'est
tout c'est pour
une seule personne
cc c'est yvonne de gaulle évidemment
c'est trop facile j'ai un temps plus que
vous étiez un an fin du général de
gaulle donc effectivement c'était pour
vous effectivement ça crée un jeu j'en
profite pour un tunnel moi j'ai une
admiration sans borne rosel des gaules
j'ai à dire je prends tous y compris les
défauts du du grand homme il ya un truc
incroyable qu'on a complètement oublié
c'est que il remboursait quand il
habitait sa famille à déjeuner au palais
et remboursait et qu'on son chéquier
personnel et les payer l'électricité
aussi je crois ou alors c'était une
bonne qui ramenait petits pois donc oui
et d'ailleurs le livre que vous avez
choisi c'est les mémoires de de gaulle
c'est un livre qui vous accompagnent
écoutez moi depuis tout petit je suis
absolument fasciné par le personnage
est pas du tout famille alors j'ai déjà
résistant je m'accompagne biens sont
dans ma famille mais j'ai pas de famille
militants et repères j'ai pas été emmené
au congrès où là à la manif de mai-68 va
pas là mais soit mais c'est là la
meilleure gaulliste et donc j'ai lu tout
fait ou non j'ai pas tout lui parce
qu'il ya beaucoup ma rage et des
dizaines et dizaines de bouquins sur sur
de gaulle et donc je me suis lancée il
ya un an dans un livre qui s'appelle
l'intendance suivra de gaulle et
l'économie est en fait cette phrase il a
jamais prononcée parce que contrairement
à ce qu'on prend 1,4 et de gaulle est
passionné par l'économie des d'ailleurs
quand il est prisonnier en 1919 en 1900
par dont 17 et il fait des conférences
sur l'économie de guerre seco
prisonniers donc voilà donc j'ai cette
passion et les mémoires bon c'est cette
fameuse face à commence par toute ma vie
je me suis fait une certaine idée de la
france on s'est écrit avec un style
alors qu'il n'est pas le style de
l'époque et style de l'époque cl
aujourd'hui qu'est la france est
extraordinaire
et puis à cette vision souvent teintées
de mauvaise foi mais qui fait qu' il est
seul en 40 avec les bêtes de miribel et
je sais plus qui est il dit la france
c'est moi qu'on s'est quand même
magnifique comme chaque semaine on se
donne rendez vous la semaine prochaine
pour un nouveau numéro de politique à
table c'est accepter